so let's uh do a quick review of uh last
lecture so last time we kind of did a
high level uh taxonomy of of radar
and it looks very similar to uh sonar so
in terms of the waveforms that Radars
use uh we said that there's there's two
main types you either have pulse radar
which sends these uh short uh pulses or
you have a CW or a continuous wave radar
which is continuously transmitting and
specifically there is two types of
continuous waveforms that are commonly
used in radar so we have fmcw radar
which stands for frequency modulated
continuous wave radar and that's the one
that sends these linear frequency chips
and then you can have your pmcw radar
which stands for phase modulated
continuous wave
radar which sends basically ranging
codes such as uh uh PN sequences or M
sequences exactly like GPS we haven't
talked much about PM CW yet but we'll
get to it today and then in terms of the
antenna configuration uh you can have
systems that just have one transmit and
one receive antenna and that's a single
input single output or a sizeable system
or you can have as it's called diversity
in your your antennas multiple
transmitters multiple receivers and then
that makes a mimo system you can of
course have like in between like a Simo
system which has one transmit multiple
receivers or a miso system which has
multiple transmitters single receiver
but I mean that that in my mind all of
those fall under mimo if your transmits
or receives are both are more than one
antenna I would like to just call the
mimo system just to simplify it
okay and then we basically developed a
very detailed signal model for fmcw
radar and for now we are assuming
um sorry so although everything we say
uh for for range and velocity estimation
exactly as is will apply to Mimo systems
but for now just to keep our uh you know
signal model uh a little uh simpler and
more tractable we're starting with a s
ISO system uh we will get uh get to Mimo
uh very soon so
before we look at the signal model just
remember that
um
the most common type of radar that is
used for autonomous robotics today is
mimo fmcw okay and that's like 99 of of
what's out there for this application
okay for other applications we can have
other things pmcw it's very interesting
I'll talk more about it I'm I'm
personally very much in favor of you
know seeing seeing more pmcw systems
developed and deployed but right now uh
for very practical reasons it hasn't
been widely used and deployed and and
we'll talk about it more okay so let's
look at our signal model
CW so we said that after down conversion
so after basically you mix your received
Echo with the transmitter chip you get
this if signal which is is given by this
expression here so let's break it down
uh so there's a mu that's a mu and Alpha
are just constants okay so you can
completely ignore them basically for the
purpose of DSP but this is for
completeness uh included here mu is the
gain of your lonose amplifier on the
receive uh receiver front end Alpha is
the attenuation uh from you know the
round trip wave propagation and also the
RF reflectivity of your target so all of
that is lumped into just one complex
Factor Alpha and then you have basically
a Time varying term with frequency Delta
f e to the J 2 pi Delta f t so so so so
that's the frequency of the if signal
Delta F and then you have a phase term
which doesn't change over time but it
depends on the round trip to lake house
so we just call that e to the J Phi of
Tau so this is our phase term
essentially and that's our frequency
um or time varying term okay so what is
uh specifically Delta F we showed that
there is uh uh basically two the two
things contributing to the frequency of
the of the if signal there's the F sub T
which is uh proportional to range okay
so ft is just your slew rate times the
round trip delay or time of flight Tau
which becomes equal to 2 times the slew
rate times the target range divided by
the speed of light okay so that's the
first term but there's also a
contribution from the Doppler effect so
the the frequency is actually Doppler
shifted by f f sub D which is our
Doppler frequency and specifically F sub
D is proportional to the relative radial
velocity between the radar and the uh
the target via this expression it's
-2 times the time derivative of range
and the time derivative is that relative
radial velocity times the carry
frequency over C or you can just write r
dot as V sub R to make it more clear
that that's a radial velocity so your FD
is -2 VR FC over C okay and this is a we
said it's it's a complication when it
comes to how do we process this uh if
signal to to do range and and and
velocity estimation because it couples
range and velocity and if we can only
measure a Delta F then how do we break
it down to like what was range what was
velocity it's it's a big uh complication
it turned out that for most robotic
application this is actually a very
little consequence why because this
Doppler shift term turns out to be much
much smaller than ft which is range
dependent and for for practical purposes
in most robotic applications you can
just ignore this there okay and then
your Delta F becomes equal to Ft which
is just a basically a function of range
okay so we we checked with some you know
um numbers that are actually kind of a
pretty conservative estimate so we
assume a Target going at 100 miles per
hour that was just a few meters in front
of the receiver and receiver working at
77 gigahertz even for that case we
showed that your ft is less than one
percent uh of uh or F Doppler is less
than one percent of Ft so that's why we
can we can ignore it but this is one of
those cases that it's extremely
extremely important to remember these
assumptions that go into our algorithms
and the DSP because you might be working
on some different application say you're
working on a military radar that that is
supposed to track missiles and missiles
can go I don't know 10 or 100 times
faster than this maybe and then this
assumption breaks down and then if you
use your vanilla DSP of course it is not
going to work so so extremely important
to remember these and every application
you're working on just check your you
know parameters against these
assumptions and make sure they're valid
for you know what I call everyday
robotics this is fine right I mean we
don't work with things that go faster
than 100 miles per hour even in like
autonomous driving that's a very uh very
conservative assumption usually okay
so that's that and then this this uh Phi
of T the phase term uh it's given by
this expression uh 2 pi times K
frequency minus beta over 2 times Tau
we'll get back to this today for now
it's just a phase term uh because we're
we're working on how do we do ranging uh
how do we do range estimation when it
comes to Doppler we'll start looking at
this actually we'll do that today uh
okay any questions about the signal
model here
okay so let's continue uh and then uh we
said that in the more General case if
you have more than
um one target
the exact same same signal model
basically applies if you have K targets
uh you just sum up the if signals that
you're receiving from each of them okay
so it just becomes this sum so each has
its own attenuation Alpha I and each is
has its own frequency Delta f i and its
own phase term Phi of Tau I okay you
just sum over all Targets so here's just
one um simple you know visual example
you have an antenna with a very wide
a radiation pattern or gain pattern so
it's it's almost isotropic and then uh
the the chip that you send in this case
it has hit three targets simultaneously
uh at ranges R1 R2 and R3 and then you
receive all three Echoes
um almost at the same time so if you
look at uh basically this plot here it
kind of shows what what what you're
receiving so the green is uh the the the
the the frequency versus time for the
transmitted chirp and then you receive
three trips back each with a a different
delay so call them Tau one Tau two and
Tau three and each of them basically
induces a frequency in your if signal
that is proportional to the range of
that Target so you get a Delta F1 a
Delta F2 and a Delta F3 right
um so so so this naturally just extends
to a case with multiple targets so now
um we are ready to do a range estimation
right because we know that these Delta
F's are proportional to range right uh
it's it's just equal to two uh make sure
I get it right from the board two times
the slew rate times the range of I
Target divided by the speed of light
that's what the Delta F's are so again
exactly like the case of of ctfm sonar
now we have converted by using these
chips a range or a time of flight
estimation problem to a frequency
estimation problem now we need to
estimate the frequency of this if signal
again as I said multiple times there's
tons of different algorithms that work
when it comes to a spectral estimation
or frequency estimation the simplest one
is our good old Fourier transform right
you just take a Fourier transform and
you're expecting to see Peaks at these
Delta F frequencies and that's exactly
uh what happens so if if you just take
your if signal and remember this is the
if signal from one chip right so you
have down converted one chirp
if down converted that that's that's the
Sif that you get and the ADC has has
sampled it so you get endpoints or n
samples in it
so n samples corresponding to one down
converted chip then you do an endpoint
fft on it and here I'm kind of loosely
using the term fft I mean we all know
fft is the actual algorithm the
implementation of the Discrete Fourier
transform so to be mathematically
correct I should really call this DFT
the Discrete Fourier transform but I
mean just for convenience we are all you
know when you program you just write fft
I mean technically ffts are designed and
they're most efficient when N is a power
of two uh but I mean you can extend it
and it will work for for any n okay so
uh just a quick note throughout the the
rest of the course I'm going to just
constantly say fft but I mean
mathematically speaking to be you know
mathematically correct that's a Discrete
Fourier transform fft is just the
algorithm that is used to calculate the
Discrete Fourier transform for you you
there's other algorithms you could use
something like the trip Z transform or
other things but but again the point is
you take a Discrete Fourier transform
and uh so you get this what we call
called the Sif of K now K is the index
of your
Fourier transform and what you need to
do is just look at the the absolute
value of f or the magnitude of F and
find the Peaks and those Peaks would
give you the Delta F though your
estimates of of your Delta F so for
example in the in the in the case of the
what I showed you in the previous
Library we had three targets if you do
that we'll see Three Peaks in the in the
fft at indices K hat one k hat two and K
hat three
and then to actually find the range of
of the targets uh you you first convert
the indices to frequencies right
um so the indices go from zero to n
minus one because you are doing an
endpoint uh fft here uh to find the
frequencies you just uh do uh your index
divided by n which is the total number
of points in the fft times the sampling
rate F sub s f sub s is your ADC
sampling so that converts your index K
to your Delta F frequency and then from
Delta F to range that's another scaling
right which which we just looked at so
so to find the range of the I Target you
do Delta F times the speed of light
divided by two times this low rate and a
slow rate remember is known because we
know what troops we're sending B is
known uh it's actually a configurable
parameter usually you can set what slew
rate you want at your transmitter so so
this is it basically
that's uh K is the index where you see
the peak in the fft times the sampling
rate of the ADC times the speed of light
divided by 2 times the number of points
in your down converter signal times slew
rate that gives you range in meters
and you're done right so that's that's
how you do uh ranging uh it's that's an
algorithm it's just a Fourier transform
it's an unbiased estimator it's very
efficient and easy to implement and it's
widely used yes
and yes good question what do I mean by
unbiased so by unbiased estimator I mean
that
um I'm going to explain it a little
Loosely because on Madison like
statistics it I mean it's there's like I
don't want to go through the full math
but Loosely speaking it means that
um if I do this run this algorithm many
many times okay and I I average all
those are hats that I estimate the
average is equal to the true ground
truth underlying R there is no no
systematic error in my measurement as
opposed to if you remember in the case
where we were talking about sonar with a
simple thresholding detector that was a
bias estimator because that there was
always then then measurement would never
be equal to the underlying ground truth
there would always be you know some
systematic area so unbiased means no
systematic error there's still noise in
your estimate but the average of the
noise is zero or the average of the
error that you make in your estimate is
zero that's what we mean by unbiased
okay
so that's that's how we do ranging okay
now uh what is the from this algorithm
what is the range resolution and what is
the maximum range that we can get
um exactly like the case of sonar the
resolution is the is determined by
basically the width of the ffd bins
right so the minimum frequency you can
discriminate is one fft bin like I can
go from K to K plus one and that's the
minimum frequency discrimination you can
do and so that determines our range
resolution and maximum range is
determined by the maximum frequency we
can estimate which is basically tied to
the sampling rate of the ADC so if the
Peaks is is at basically n minus 1
that's the maximum frequency you can
distinguish and then that determines the
maximum rate so mathematically what we
get is minimum range discrimination uh
corresponds to one fft bin so what is
the frequency for one fft bin that's
just your sampling rate FS divided by
the total number of points in your fft
which is also equal to 1 over T where T
is remember the trip duration in seconds
because you have this relationship
between the number of samples the trip
duration and the sampling rate okay so
with that Delta F minimum what is the
minimum range that you can discriminate
you can just plug that Delta F Min into
our range equation so Delta R minimum
which is our range resolution becomes
Delta s minimum times speed of light
divided by 2B
and you plug this into here from the top
and then your Delta R Min becomes C over
2 B times t or speed of light divided by
two times the bandwidth of the chirp
right and remember the bandwidth of the
chirp is if you look at this frequency
versus time the bandwidth of the chip is
if you go from FC
to FC plus slew rate times T where T is
the total chip duration this is
our trip bandwidth B which is slew rate
times the total duration this is exactly
the same expression by the way we got
for ctfm sonar no changes because it's
you know same principle of operation
same algorithm so it makes sense that
you get the same basically type of
performance out of it what about the
maximum range maximum range is
again the maximum frequency you can find
in your fft times the speed of light
divided by 2B what is the maximum
frequency well you're searching we know
that range is always positive by
definition so we when we look at our fft
at Delta F can be from 0 to the maximum
which is the sampling rate fs and this
is from the Nyquist basically uh theorem
so we plug in basically our F Delta F
Max is the sampling rate plug that in
and that is the maximum range which is
sampling rate times the speed of light
divided by 2B okay so here immediately
we see one of those basically trade-offs
between your range resolution and the
maximum range that you can discriminate
why because let's say you keep every
parameter the same and we are just
varying this slew rate okay so if if you
uh increase the slew rate B what happens
to Delta R Delta R uh if you increase
speed it likes it right because Delta R
becomes a smaller that means you get
better range resolution so it's good for
a Delta R Delta R goes up uh or it goes
down actually which is desirable
but also the maximum range goes down
which is undesirable so it will increase
your range resolution but decrease the
maximum range okay so that's a very
important you know uh trade-off if if
you're in charge of you know
designing or using a radar for some
application you one of the design
parameters you need to choose if it's a
fmcw radar is going to be this slew rate
and then you have to look at your
application decide what is the maximum
range you need to see what is the range
resolution that is required and then
based on those decide what is the
optimal B to use and there's it's a
trade-off so you some somebody needs to
you know give something and you cannot
you know have the best possible
resolution and the best possible maximum
range there's always this trade-off
between the two okay any yes
like Radars I work at these frequencies
like are do they ever do real sampling
or is it usually always IQ uh great
question so the question is The Radars
that operate we're talking about at
these frequencies uh that when it comes
to the ADC sampling did it do real
samples or IQ samples for fmcw it's it's
always IQ samples because uh we need to
have the full complex signal uh as we'll
see in a second especially to do you
know Doppler frequency estimation that
phase term needs to be known uh
basically we need to have this e to the
J Phi of T and as we know the only way
you can find the phase is to have the
full complex signal or both the I and
the Q component so it's it's always it's
always full IQ yeah physically you get
out of your ADC I mean
you can't you know and and in Circus you
can't have you know complex signals so
it gives you two data streams one for
iPhone for Q as you know and then in DSP
you mix them and make a complex uh
signal out of it uh okay so other
questions
all right let's continue so now we are
uh we want to talk about velocity
estimation we know how to how to do
range right and next is velocity and
velocity here it's uh basically the
velocity from the Doppler shift which as
we know it's the relative radial
velocity okay uh so it's that v r that
that we are going to see how to estimate
so it's not going to give us the full
you know velocity Vector of the target
uh it will only give us the the
component that's projected to the radial
Direction uh still extremely useful
right but that's that's an important
thing to know that the velocity that you
get is just a radial velocity okay as I
as I told you uh that's where this phase
term Phi of Tau becomes very important
because this does contain Doppler
information in it now to see how
velocity estimation works first let's
look at a very simple example just two
chips sent consecutively from the
transmitter and they are echoed by back
from the same Target okay so two chirps
here shown in green and then you get two
Echoes In Blue uh from from the Target
and uh let's say your round trip Delay
from uh the target was from the first
trip you get Tau one from the second
trip you get uh Tao two why did it
change because we're assuming the target
has some velocity because it has some
radial velocity between the two chips it
moves slightly and that slight movement
can affect your round trip uh delay or
time of flight time okay
so
um so target has some radial velocity V
sub R relative to the antenna
and here
we're assuming that uh basically within
this small time a t that has passed
between the two chips so this first chip
was sent at Time Zero the second is is
sent at at time uh Big T and because
this big T is typically very small so
these are on the orders of like tens of
microseconds basically for for the types
of Radars that uh we're we're talking
about or or sometimes even less than 10
microseconds because it's such a small
time it lapse between the two
consecutive chips well the target does
move if it has the radial velocity but
it doesn't move enough for that change
in the uh uh basically in the target
range to affect the if
uh frequency Delta F okay so again the
Assumption here is that the operator
term does not affect Delta F which is
exactly the same assumption we talked
about a few minutes ago so Delta f is
the same between the two consecutive
chirps but nevertheless uh the the round
trip delay is changing a little bit
and that would affect R5 because Phi is
only a function of of Tau how much does
does it affect Phi so uh let's let's uh
look at it so as you know Phi so let's
first look at the Phi 1 which is the
phase of the the down converted signal
from the first chip
okay so you have like Sif one of T from
here and you get a s i f 2 of T from
this one so what is Phi 1 the expression
for it was 2 pi FC minus beta over 2
over Tau okay but if you look at the
numbers B times Tau
um is always again for the applications
we work with uh uh is much much less
than the carrier frequency FC like B tau
is typically a few megahertz
carrier frequency as you know it's like
24 gigahertz or 77 gigahertz so your B
time style is like a thousand to ten
thousand times a smaller than FC so
inside here you can you can assume this
is almost zero in comparison to FC and
then your Phi just becomes 2 pi times
the carry frequency times Tau 1. just
like that what is the phase of the
second if signal that becomes 2 pi FC
Tau two right so the phases are directly
proportional to the Taos okay so now
let's look at the phase difference
between these two if signals so I'm
going to subtract the phase of the
second if signal from the phase of the
first if signal and see how much between
the two chips the phase of the signal we
receive has changed so that Delta Phi
Phi 2 minus Phi 1 let's plug in so it
becomes 2 pi Delta times carrier
frequency times Delta Tau and what is
Delta Tau that's just Delta range
divided by C that's that's by definition
times two right so that's why you get a
4 here so so remember tau is 2R over C
so your Delta Tau becomes 2
Delta R over C and that's what we've
plugged in here you can write it like
this 2 pi T times 2fc Delta r divided by
c times T where T is the the chirp
duration in seconds but here's something
interesting this Delta R over t
that's how much the range changed over T
seconds so that's the radial velocity of
of your Target or the relative radial
velocity between the Target and the
radar so that's VR or almost equal to VR
if if T is small which we know is and
then this term here 2fc VR over C that's
our
basically Doppler shift by by definition
so you see that this Delta Phi between
the two consecutive chips that the phase
difference is proportional in fact to
the the Doppler shift okay
um
so now that that's the case that means
if we estimate or calculate the phase
difference between two consecutive
chirps we can then estimate Doppler
shift from that right so from this
expression then you just basically uh
invert that and you get your estimate of
the Doppler shift is just Delta Phi
divided by 2 pi T again T is the chirp
duration okay and from the Doppler shift
we can find the relative
radial velocity between the Target and
the and the radar which as we know is
just minus FD times Lambda over 2 Lambda
is the wavelength in terms of the Phi
it's it's this expression okay so that
is in principle how you can estimate
velocity in a fmcw radar yes
if you have a mango array then how to
say like what is the radio velocity with
us with respect to our future that's a
great question so uh the question is
we're talking about radial velocity
um but what if we have a mimo array then
with respect to this radials with
respect to which antenna so if I were to
draw it if I have like multiple antennas
right and then there is a target when we
talk about radial velocity this is
radial with respect to this this is a
radial with respect to this is a radial
with respect to that right that was the
question uh well it that's that's a very
valid question but this is only I think
this picture is kind of like
um exaggerated in the sense that the
target is like so close to the antenna
plane that the ranges are actually
different uh when we're talking about
you know far field targets the target is
actually like way out here so yes we
assume that that range is you know the
same to all of
like the antennas are so close to each
other relative to how far the target is
that the range is the same to to all of
the antennas that's and that's a good
assumption I mean usually your your
antenna aperture is like a couple of
inches by a couple of inches and then if
your target is like 20 30 meters away or
even 10 5 meters away
you can assume the range is almost the
same respect to you know all of the all
of the antennas uh but but but again
that's a great question because that's
one of the assumptions that in some
applications might not be valid like if
your target is like too close then yes
that you can pick up different uh
dopplers on different antennas because
because of exactly uh what what you
brought up uh but but for us we assume
that yeah it's Target is far away the
range is almost the same with respect to
all the antennas and the antennas are
really close to each other
estimated tangential velocity
um yes you can it becomes complicated uh
but well not like complicated to the
point that you cannot do it but you can
absolutely do that uh then you need to
you know find Doppler with respect to
every antenna and then from by comparing
those dopplers then you can also find
tangential velocity I'm sure I haven't
seen anybody do it makes for an
interesting research problem I guess but
it's doable
um okay so that's that's how we find
Doppler from just two consecutive chips
and there is a limit to you know what
velocity you can find why is there a
limit because note that we're we're uh
it's it's based on that that uh phase
shift between two consecutive chips and
if the phase shift is bigger than Pi or
smaller than minus Pi it wraps around
the circle and then basically becomes
ambiguous right so this is this is valid
as long as you're Delta Phi is less than
Pi bigger than minus Pi okay okay that's
important so that limits what is the
maximum velocity you can unambiguously
detect so what is the maximum velocity
or the absolute value of the maximum
velocity you can unambiguously detect
that is proportional to the maximum
phase you can unambiguously detect which
is pi so you plug in pi into this
expression for Delta Phi and then the pi
and the pi numerator denominator cancel
out and you you get Lambda over 4T which
is the maximum velocity so the radial
velocity you can estimate is between
Lambda over 4T and minus Lambda over 40.
that's that's the limit and and again if
if you if you need to
um
uh uh increase that limit on what
velocity you can detect what one thing
you can do is well either you can go to
higher frequencies lambdos so that's one
reason like 77 gigahertz is better than
24 one of the many reasons or you can
reduce T so send shorter chips basically
and that helps with your unambiguous
velocity uh okay so this this
one way you can estimate velocity but
just looking at two concept negative
chirps it's it's not a very robust
algorithm because remember like in
reality these signals are distorted
they're noisy so if you just look at two
chips and compare the phase of the two
you get a really really noisy estimate
of of that phase difference which
becomes a very noisy estimate of your
Doppler shift and ultimately velocity to
robustify this idea
what you can do is basically extend it
and instead of just looking at two chips
look at a whole bunch of them look at
tens or hundreds right but the core idea
is exactly the same so what is done in
practice to robustify this velocity
estimation algorithm is that you define
what is called a frame
okay and the frame is basically a
collection of M chirps that are sent
consecutively remember that your
transmitter is just constantly it's a
CWU system right it's just constantly
sending these chirps forever right on
the receiver so the ndsp you can define
a frame and it's up to you like how long
you you take your frame to be but you
just collect a bunch of if signals M of
them right trip zero to chip M and you
decide what
what is a good choice for M uh typically
it's like a few tens to a couple hundred
or something like that so I've seen like
numbers between 32 to you know 512 or so
but you choose some M and then uh that
makes up for a frame of data and then
instead of looking at just two
consecutive chips you look at all of
them and then estimate your Doppler but
the core idea is exactly the same so
what happens and here our notation is
going to get slightly more complex so
let's make sure things make sense so I'm
calling now Sif I'm assigning two
indices to the if signals a m and an N
so Sif
of M and N
m is the chip index okay so that means
this Sif is coming from which of the M
chips inside the frame so little M goes
from 0 to M minus 1.
and little n is the ADC sample index
just like we had before so little n goes
from those are the samples you get out
of your ADC so that goes from zero to
Big N minus one because we're sampling
each Chip N times okay so that's our
annotation just to make sure it's clear
so uh now if you look at the phases of
these Sif of M and N the first one Asif
as 0 for m equals zero and let's call
that phase of uh that guy just Phi zero
that's our reference phase that's like
this the phase at the start of the frame
okay we just call that Phi zero it's
equal to two Pi FC Tau 0 okay that's our
reference but then every uh chip that
comes after that in the frame it has a
phase Phi M which is Phi 0 plus M times
the Delta 5. Delta Phi is that phase
difference we just calculated between
two consecutive chips so the the phase
the chip that comes
um you know after M chirps it's just has
a phase difference of M times Delta Phi
with respect to the first one right and
what is the assumption that goes into
here we're assuming that the radial
velocity is constant within one frame
and because of that the Delta Phi of
every two consecutive chirps becomes
constant and we know what Delta Phi was
right Delta Phi was just minus two pi
times Doppler frequency times T so the
phase of the M
if signal number M becomes Phi zero
minus two Pi F Doppler times M which is
the tube index times T which is the
chair duration
okay so what is the total time of one
frame uh it it consists of M chirps and
each chip has a time of T So a frame
time TF is equal to M times T which is
the trip time okay
all right so uh what is our new signal
model what for for one one full frame so
Sif of M and N there's nothing new here
so it's equal to Mu times Alpha so Mu
Alpha is again the gain and the
attenuation Factor this is our good old
frequency term that we had e to the J2
Pi Delta F times NTS I'm writing the
discrete version here so that's why you
get n times t s t s is the sampling
interval of the ADC and N remember is
the ADC index okay so that's and Delta f
is the term that is proportional to
range and then you get e to the J Phi 0
so that's the starting phase of the
first chirp and then this e to the minus
J2 Pi F Doppler Mt that is basically
coming from here which was Phi zero plus
and Delta Phi so so again this
expression here is exactly what we had
here
same signal model right we have just
expanded what Phi would be
for chips that are inside a frame that's
that's all we had done there's no new
physics no new you know uh pretty uh uh
exactly there's no new physics here
we've just expanded the math to include
you know uh to to be able to talk about
frames instead of individual individual
chips so um again when you see
expressions like this I mean at first
glance they look kind of you know too
much too too digest but always you know
take a deep breath and go term by term
and make sure everything makes sense
again let's do it together one more time
mu is the gain Alpha is attenuation this
is our good old e to the J 2 pi Delta f
t we have just discretized it through
the ADC uh this e to the J Phi zero is
the starting phase at the very beginning
of the frame and then this is the just e
to the J 2 pi and and this here is like
M Delta Phi
that's that's what it is e to the G now
what's really interesting here is now we
have this complex exponential term which
is proportional the frequency of it is
the Doppler shift and it's sampled at a
different sampling rate it's sampled at
you know every every T seconds which is
a chip a trip time so here we have a
different sampling rate for Delta F
Delta f is sampled at TS which is our
ADC sampling time and that's fast that's
why this is called fast time and then
our Doppler is sampled slowly because
it's sampled between chips and and
that's every T seconds and this is
usually called slow time in the in the
context of radar so how do we process
this processing turns out to be
extremely extremely easy before we do
that you can even make it you know more
General if you have k k targets
uh what happens you just sum K of these
one one for each Target that that is
that is echoing back to you so it's the
exact same expression mu is Mu because
it's the same gain for all Targets but
then now every Target going from one to
K has its own attenuation Factor its own
Delta F which is proportional to the
range of the ith Target it contributes a
Phi 0 to the starting phase of the frame
and it has this term which is the phase
of the if signal and it has uh it's it's
proportional to the Doppler frequency
which as we know gives us v r i which is
the relative
relative radial velocity of the I Target
okay so that's the general signal model
and uh here two assumptions go into the
signal model so we have assumed that
within one frame both the target range
and the target the loss or radial
velocity of the target are almost
constant okay so the frame should be
long enough
uh should be short enough that both
these assumptions are valid R doesn't
change too much for each Target and v r
doesn't change too much so that means
the frame should be short enough but
also should be long enough such that it
gives us enough chirps so that we can
estimate Doppler accurately what are
some typical numbers for uh you know
reasonable frame times for applications
we are interested in
no more than 100 milliseconds I would
say if it goes above 100 milliseconds
except if things are moving really
really slowly that's where I would start
to worry like are these assumptions are
still valid or not and 100 milliseconds
frame time that's like a 10 frames a
second radar so it's it's it's something
you know very interesting
of course if you can work with shorter
frames it's better because that means
these assumptions are even more more
valid but if things start to become too
long in your frame or if the frame
duration starts to become too long you
should plug in some numbers for you know
typical range typical velocity that you
get and see okay are assumptions are
still valid or not that that went into
the signal model okay how do we process
this processing is a two-step thing
uh first step is the same as as we did
before so first you do range estimation
which is just an endpoint fft okay but
now your signal has is a function of of
two indices you have n and you have M
right so your first fft is along the N
axis and that is called the range fft or
range processing
so when you do range processing you
basically just take the fft of this if
signal over n okay and that's n big
endpoint fft so everything that doesn't
depend on N you can just take them out
of the of the ffd sum or integral so mu
is Mu Alpha I is Alpha I this stuff is
also you can take them out because
they're not functions of n the only term
that has end dependence is is this e to
the J 2 pi Delta f i n t s which is the
same thing we had before when we did our
ranging so you take the fft of that call
that ffd I'm calling it artillery I of K
okay in fact I'm also in this rtdi I'm
also including that the constant so the
alpha I the MU and the e to the J Phi is
there I'm also lumping those into all
right just to simplify the math right
so RI is our range of fft and we know
from what we just discussed that for
each Target if you look at the magnitude
of RTD I it will have a Peak at an index
that is proportional to the range of
that Target in fact it will show a Peak
at an index K hat I which is equal to n
times Delta F hat I over fs and Delta F
at I is proportional to RI or R hat I
which is the range of the ice target
okay so range processing converts your
raw if signal into something that shows
peaks in indices proportional to the
range of the targets now look at this we
have something very interesting as a
function of M what we have here is just
this complex exponential right
it's it's like a complex exponential
with a frequency that is the Doppler
frequency of the ice target FDI so if we
take now an fft over m
that should give us Peaks that are
proportional to the Doppler frequencies
right so again now our Doppler
estimation or velocity estimation became
a spectral estimation or a frequency
estimation problem we need to estimate
these fdis simplest algorithm is a
Fourier transform so let's do that so
now you do a second one-dimensional
endpoint fft along the M axis this is
called Doppler ffd or Doppler processing
so now we take the fft over m
of the already fft or pre-processed if
signal and this time you can take the
artillery out of the fft because that
does not depend on M so you just fft
this complex exponential term and let's
call that detail the I of L okay so dtl
IFL it will show Peaks at indices L that
are proportional to the Doppler shifts
or Doppler frequencies of individual
targets very specifically for the I
Target if you look at the magnitude of
dtldi it will show a Peak at uh at L Hat
eyes and the Doppler shifts are just L
hat over M which is the number of points
in the fft times this F Prime s what is
f Prime s is the sampling rate in the in
the Doppler axis okay and the Doppler
axis we said we are slow time so we are
sampling at 1 over T rate so F Prime s
which is 1 over T is the effective
sampling rate along the Doppler axis and
uh it it basically becomes minus L hat I
over TF so that's the estimate of the uh
of the Doppler shift of the ice target
and doubler shift we can also easily
convert that to radial velocities uh
radial velocities our Doppler minus
Doppler times Lambda over two if you
plug everything in in terms of the
indices at which you see the Peaks along
the Doppler axis uh if you multiply them
by Lambda divide by two times the frame
time that gives you the radial
velocities of The Targets in meters per
second I know the math becomes you know
a bit a bit dense here so this is the
kind of a thing you have to you know sit
down and and go through it at your own
pace and make sure every step makes
sense but I very intentionally you know
left nothing out when it comes to
writing down the math and you know uh
clarifying all the assumptions because I
think it's important to get comfortable
to work you know at this level of of
mathematical complexity again the point
here is that you know
even like lots of textbooks when it
comes to DSP they just tell you oh range
and Doppler processes are just two ffts
go do it and you're done and of course
well yes and no right I mean yes and
again 95 of the cases but there's a lot
of assumptions that go into this and
it's important I think really really
important for you to know where where
those assumptions were made what are the
assumptions and at the end of the day
why why if the fft is just or Fourier
Transformer is just a convenient
algorithm that lets us find these
frequencies we are looking for there's
nothing you know sacred about fft you
could you could do another many many
different you know algorithms exist that
or can be used for spectral estimation
so fft again it's it's standard because
it's efficient and easy and convenient
to use but you can actually in terms of
performance beat ffd by a long margin if
you if you use you know more
sophisticated algorithms so let's look
at this graphically hopefully this next
slide kind of you know it instead of
math gets really dense but this is
visually really at the end of the day
what happens it's a very very simple
process to do range and Doppler
estimation so the way to read this it's
like four blocks so so you start here so
that's number one you go from one to two
two to three three to four okay so let's
go together one is there's there's
nothing happening in one so this just
from your ADC signals coming in
raw signal okay so you take one frame of
data and you just populate it in an M by
n Matrix so you have in rows are your
index n which is ADC samples and columns
are the chip index so you get you put
your first if signal from the first chip
in the in the first row Sif 0n the
second if goes in the second row third
one goes in the third row and so on all
the way to the amps one okay
so that's just you know ordering your
data before you process it now you want
to do range and Doppler processing to do
range processing you fft each row every
row of the Matrix just do a n big end
point
fft on it and that converts basically
eight ADC samples to the range index k
and we call that rtld right so you get
rtdk rtdk rtdk on the rows but each is
Multiplied each row is multiplied by a
different complex exponential that is
proportional to the Doppler shift so you
get first one is multiplied by just e to
the J zero second one e to the J2 Pi F
DTS third one e to the J2 Pi f d two t
and so on and so forth okay so that's
your range processing doubler processing
now you take ffts of each every column
right so ffd every column this is going
to be an endpoint fft because you have
endpoints and again remember every cell
here is one ADC sample one ADC sample so
it's just one number one complex number
in every cell right so so that's that's
our data Matrix basically
so ffd the columns and then that
converts your chip index to adopter
shift and XL right and that's why we
call that after the fft we call it dtld
of L so now if if you look at your cell
uh basically KL that gives you what we
call Sif big Sif of KNL
and then the K is proportional to the
basically to the uh
range and L so K is range index and L is
Doppler index or velocity index
how do you convert these indices to
physical quantities that is range in
meters velocity in meters per second
those are simple scalings right these
are the things we had seen before so
from from this to make what is called a
range velocity map what you do is first
you take the magnitude of this Matrix
after the two ffts because it's going to
be complex valued but you look at the
magnitude of it and then to go from
indices to physical you know range in
meters velocity in meters per second
let's zoom in here you do scaling so
your range becomes like K times FSC over
2mb I mean these are the things that we
had seen before Doppler becomes minus L
over Mt and then velocity from Doppler
is minus Doppler shift times Lambda over
2. now after you scale your two axes
according to these you end up with here
the visualization is is color is is
basically the value in DB so it goes
from -30 to 30 DB and then the two axes
one is range in meters one is velocity
meters per second it is called a range
velocity map but note it's not the map
that we intend it's just a term used in
in radar terminology so it's not mapping
the sense of you know the the geometric
representation of what the scene looks
like because we haven't done direction
of arrival yet but it's still very
useful because it tells you you know
kind of a lot of information so looking
at this it's you can read it as kind of
like a heat map if you will and and
where you have peaks in here like here
that's a Target right everywhere that
the values are low this is just noise
so ignore that and then where you have
you know big values those are those are
where the targets are so here for
instance I can tell that I probably in
this scene had a moving Target at about
say 20 meters range and a velocity of
about say minus 20 meters per second
that's one because that's a you know hot
spot in my range velocity map what is
this stuff all of this you know it's uh
spans a lot of range from very close to
far away but all at zero velocity so
that's all the static parts of the scene
right I probably had like stuff from
very close to me I don't know where this
was captured but if it was out on the
street maybe it was like you know
buildings or trees or you know anything
that's stationary from very close to
right about you know 120 130 meters
and those all show at zero velocity
slice basically in the range range
velocity map so that's how far we have
gotten so far in terms of the DSP of
fmcw radar we can do range and we can do
velocity uh estimation
one more thing is that the two ffts so
we did fft on the rows ffd on the on the
columns if you like you can combine the
two and just do a one 2D FSD that's
mathematically uh equivalent
um and uh so basically what you can do
is that you can start from your data
Matrix raw data Matrix and just do a 2d
fft on it over m and n
and that's equivalent to two separate
one dffds it's just mathematically
equivalent and that directly gives you
your range Doppler processed
basically data Matrix and again remember
RTL the eyes they have Peaks where
according where the target
according to target range and detail the
eyes they show Peaks according to the
Target velocities so when you multiply
the two you get Peaks at the correct
range and velocity of the of the target
here's another picture again this is a
little more compact so you start from
one frame of data okay coming in and
then you accumulate the if signal into
this m by n raw data Matrix
and then you can do a m by and 2D fft on
it and that gives you this Sif of lnk
and then on this or on the magnitude of
this if you do Peak search that gives
you the range and velocities of the
targets here's another visualization of
the of the range velocity map here
instead of like an image view or a heat
map view we're doing a full 3d surface
so same data it's just visualized
differently but for this one it shows
two
pretty you know significant Peak so
those correspond to two Targets looks
like in this case they were both at
around 100 meters range and one had I
don't know a velocity of like maybe
minus 15 meters per second the other one
had a velocity of maybe 30 meters per
second or something like that but the
point is from here you can detect
usually uh uh you can do Target
detection on this right so for instance
if you apply a threshold
uh and just keep everything that is
above a fixed threshold that could give
you your your targets that's one way of
you know doing uh Target detection on
this
any questions
yes
uh what is what does that magnitude mean
like kind of the signal strength of the
is signal yes after the fft so the
magnitude here is basically the norm of
this as big Sif of lnk
Port log of it
um so can it be transferred into SNR or
something
yes so if you want to estimate SNR one
way of doing it is that if you look at
part of this where you know there's no
targets
and average that that can give you kind
of like your noise
level right noise floor and then you you
take your targets and then you divide
like your your target value by the noise
floor and that gives you a measure of of
SNR but you have to know look at or
maybe the previous one is better if I go
here like over here if you know there
was no target you can just you know
average here and that gives you kind of
like your noise level and then yeah you
use that to estimate the SNR that's
that's one way of doing it
okay uh last thing we need to
um do is with this algorithm what is the
velocity resolution and maximum velocity
you can detect well it's another fft
right so the exact same argument we did
for range of flies what is the velocity
resolution it's the width of you know
one Doppler one fft bin for the uh for
the Doppler fft so when it comes to the
minimum Doppler shift that we can
discriminate that Delta f is the
sampling rate for on the Doppler axis
which was F Prime s divided by the
number of points in the Doppler fftm and
we know F Prime was just 1 over t one
over the trip time so it becomes 1 over
M times t or 1 over the total frame time
okay so if you want better Doppler
resolution you need longer frames
basically larger TF in terms of what the
exact velocity resolution is Delta V we
know how it's related to Delta f is
Delta F times Lambda over 2 and then
plug one over TF for Delta F you get
Lambda over 2 TF so to improve your
velocity resolution you need a longer
frame duration okay
and then what is the maximum velocity
you can detect maximum velocity also
corresponds to the maximum frequency
that you can detect in your Doppler fft
one very important thing is when we were
doing this for range we said range is
always positive so in the range fft we
look at frequency zero all the way to FS
velocity can be positive or negative so
when we're we're looking at your Doppler
shift in the fft you basically search
the fft from minus FS Prime over 2 to FS
Prime over 2. so you basically take it
two-sided and that's why you you you get
you get this so the maximum frequency
that you can find in your Doppler fft
before it becomes ambiguous is half the
sampling rate because because you want
to go two-sided basically so half the
sampling rate plug that in and it
becomes Lambda over 40. interestingly
both this and this are the exact same
that we got when we first did this
simple velocity estimation from just two
consecutive chips just uh I don't know
20 minutes ago we got the exact same you
know the velocity resolution and maximum
velocity again it makes sense because it
we are doing the same algorithm we just
extended it to M chirps instead of two
so it kind of makes sense that it
doesn't affect the the overall
resolution or maximum velocity okay so
here's another trade-off basically for
you uh if you keep all the parameters
constant and just decrease the chip
duration T what happens is that it will
decrease velocity resolution right why
does it decrease velocity resolution
because if you decrease T you decrease
TF you decrease TF your Delta VR goes up
so you lose velocity resolution but you
increase maximum velocity again because
your T goes down your maximum V goes up
so that's the trade-off between velocity
resolution and maximum velocity that you
can detect with this algorithm with the
fft algorithm any questions
yes why in this case do you have to um
like quote unquote
uh it's uh well it is it is Nyquist but
it it is minus FS over 2 to FS because
if this is my
frequency after after the fft and that's
that zero uh so Nyquist tells us uh you
have to be you know within the sampling
rate before things start to you know
wrap around so you can pick
your you have an overall you know
spectral width that is equal to f
Prime s you can pick your starting point
and that that determines your end point
if you know the quantity or the
frequency you're looking for is always
positive you want to start at zero and
then you go all the way to FS Prime but
for velocity we know it can be positive
or negative because the the target can
come towards you or go away from you so
then you make it symmetric you start at
minus F Prime s over two
and then you search all the way to F
Prime s over 2. and that's that's why
basically it's just because it can be
positive or negative
okay uh so uh we are kind of like
closing this this part of the DSP about
range and Doppler uh estimation or range
and velocity estimation one thing to
note is that
um when we discuss this idea of the chip
waveforms uh uh we assumed ideal chips
you know there were these you know the
chips that we looked at uh it was this
perfect frequency ramp and then
instantaneously would like Drop to zero
and then you would transmit the next one
right in reality they don't look like
this there's non-idealities in the
waveform so it's it's more like this
picture here whether realistic you know
what you get from actual Hardware so
here's just assumed like this was the
previous chip this is the next chip and
then when when you turn off your
transmitter there's you know this ugly
transition down to zero which takes some
time and it's you know there's some
wiggling around it also when you start
the ramp uh there is a little bit of you
know non-ideality at the very beginning
there's usually a kink in the frequency
so there is only a part of the full chip
that is you know constant slew rate and
nice and linear and useful okay and that
is what the actual Hardware uses so your
adcs are only sampling at the you know
nicest most linear part of the chip
because if if they don't do that all of
this you know
ugliness and and distortions will make
it into your signal and your ffts become
very very noisy and it becomes very
difficult to see what's a real Target
and and what's nice so that's important
to note also
there is always some idle time between
the previous chip and the start of the
next one okay these are typically small
I mean could be a couple microseconds
only but there is some idle time because
as you shut down your transmitter it
needs again a bit of time for it for the
transients to die off and then it's
ready to do another chip the title time
should be Factor factor in when it comes
to the sampling rate along the Doppler
axis because we said the sampling rate
is just you know just the one over the
chip duration but in reality it's
there's this T effective which is the
chip duration plus the idle time so the
frequency or the sampling rate on the
Doppler axis becomes one over the
effective chirp time which is the chip
duration plus the idle time it's very
very important and these numbers are
known like you can go either you
configure it or it's in the data sheet
of the you know of the of the
transceiver that that you're using but
when you're doing your analysis just you
have to end your DSP you have to account
your uh for that for the idle time for
sure okay
and last but not least a lot of these
parameters that we talked about and what
parameters did we talk about in terms of
the waveform parameters things like slew
rate trip duration number of chips per
frame frame duration frequent carrier
frequency a lot of these modern devices
let you configure them so they can
support you know a range of each of
these variables so again this This Ti
transceiver we looked at last time
awr2243 it's very configurable and now
that we know about these trade-offs that
for instance you can give up range but
get better range resolution or you can
give up maximum velocity you get better
velocity resolution now you go and you
know do your study according to your
application and you come up with you
know a desirable choice of these
parameters that that you can configure
your device to to use so you can you can
you know do studies like this this has
been done for for a sisal system but
specifically for for this device in this
table I can tell you which parameters
you can configure as the user of the
device so FC you can configure it and I
think it supports 76 to 81 gigahertz so
you go and specify what Center frequency
you want the standard frequency
determines Lambda because Lambda is f is
just C over Lambda so you set F and it
just kind of dictates what Lambda is you
can set the slew rate and then you look
at the data sheet it tells you a range
of slew rates that you can do you can
you can set the idle time you can set
the chip duration
and slew rate and Tube duration together
determines the bandwidth so that's not a
free parameter any anymore you can even
set the ADC sampling rate in this device
again there's range of you know
acceptable values but it's it's user
German and then once you set the
sampling rate the samples per chip is is
determined for you chips per frame you
can also determine and with all of these
set that also sets your total frame
duration for you and once you have those
these blue ones these are so the top
ones are kind of like engineering
parameters those are the ones that you
as the sensor engineer go and decide
based on some studies that you've done
and then from these
kind of you can derive the system level
parameters that determine the the
performance of the system things like
frame rate times like maximum range
range resolution maximum velocity
velocity resolution so these are the
system level performance metrics so
here's for instance three configurations
that somebody has designed for for this
and those are for like a long range
application a medium range application
and short-range application I wouldn't
go through the full table but something
should make sense so for instance short
range what is the maximum range so short
range sees up to 62 meters long range
sees up to 250 meters okay so what
parameter is changed here so for
instance if you look at the slew rates
that were chosen short range has a
higher slew rate long range has a lower
slew rate or if you look at for instance
the ADC sampling rate you see that short
range has a lower sampling rate and the
long range has a longer sample larger
sampling rate and based on the
trade-offs that we discussed this should
make sense because for instance you know
how how changes in slew rate or sampling
rate affect maximum range and range
resolution
Okay so
like these numbers are not set in stone
um you as this as the engineer uh who
who is working on an application should
go and and design uh and decide what
what are the right parameters for your
applications there are some tools that
I'm not a big fan of but I should let
you know that uh exists so for instance
TI provides this this online tool to you
know design uh chirps for their
transceivers so you go on their website
and you decide what device you're using
so these are all the ti you know
millimeter wave transceivers go with
2243 you pick up the number of transmit
and and receiver antennas here they're
doing it the other way around so you
give them like what parameters you want
like this is the maximum range I want
this is the maximum velocity I want and
so on and so forth and then it kind of
calculates the uh the the chair
parameters that that you want to give
the device in terms of you know the the
frequencies slope is the slew rate and
and you know the sampling rate and so on
and so forth and then you can go program
the device accordingly I'm not a fan of
this because this sort of becomes a bit
black boxy and it hides you know the the
low level trade-offs that that we talked
about now that you know how all these
parameters are related you should do
your own analysis and you know come up
because again these are trade-offs and
when it concentrate-offs you should
decide what's the right you know
trade-offs to make you shouldn't let
some black box algorithm on a TI website
that God knows which entrant wrote when
decide the fate of your you know
application
any questions yes
four
okay so T effective and the question was
for Ranger for range resolution uh
let me think about that for range
resolution
uh no that that wouldn't get affected
because range resolution goes with ADC
if that's fast time right fast time is
ADC sampling rate and and that's
unaffected you're just you know sampling
on yours your slow time gets affected by
the idle time because that adds to the
to separation between consecutive chips
okay
very good and then
um so so that's that's so far the
discussion about we finished the
discussion about range and velocity
estimation for fmcw and we haven't
talked about direction of arrival yet
we'll get to that but before that I want
to very briefly talk about pmcw radar
you're not going to go as much in depth
although the the full detail is in the
slides if you're interested I can read
about it but here's a high level block
diagram of a pmcw radar again remember
that the main difference is the waveform
right so these Radars send ranging codes
for for waveforms so it can be like a
maximum length sequence or an M sequence
exactly like GPS or other types of codes
with good autocorrelation basically
properties and then you modulate that
with some carrier frequency
you pass it through an amplifier and
transmit that and then on the receive
side again it's the same physics right
so you get a attenuated delayed and
Doppler shifted version of what you see
and your down conversion here is simpler
you just down convert by the carrier
frequency instead of as opposed to down
converting by the full you know waveform
that you transmitted like we did in fmcw
so down converter is is just simple it's
exactly the same as again GPS receiver
filter it pass it to the ADC and you do
your range and velocity estimation so at
a very high level the way the ranging uh
works I think this picture is a good one
to look at so you you transmit a ranging
code M sequences are very common uh for
for pmcw Radars and then you receive so
the green is what you transmit call that
sft and then your the if signal that you
receive after that down conversion if
there is no Doppler shift it's just
going to be a delayed and attenuated
version of your your transmitter and
then as as we know from GPS if you if
you correlate the two that correlation
is going to have a p
at an index that is proportional to the
round trip time of flight delay and you
can then convert the Tau to to range
right so R is basically uh
Tau over 2C
okay sorry Tau C over 2.
did I get this right
I think so
yeah
um
so that's super high level how the the
pmcw rate works now as I said today it's
it's not as widely deployed uh as as
fmcw actually you cannot go and buy an
off-the-shelf fully integrated you know
pmcw transceiver which is kind of sad
because it's in my mind from our
architecture and DSP point of view it's
a more interesting more capable
technology I hope we'll see more of it
the main reason uh if if you're
interested know why pmcw is not as
deployed as fmcw is basically this ADC
that you need for for pmcw to get
comparable performance to fmcw you need
much much higher sampling rates and by
much much higher I mean something like a
factor of thousand to ten thousand times
faster you need like Giga samples per
second or multi-giga samples per second
adcs for pmcw as opposed to megahertz or
tons of kilohertz per second adcs or
kilo samples per second ADC for fmcw and
that makes today the pmcw a more
expensive device to manufacture because
it becomes more power hungry and more
expensive to to build in Silicon but
that's changing I mean year over year we
know how silicon technology works these
these things get faster cheaper better
over time so I think soon we're going to
see more and more you know ready to go
TurnKey off the shelf pmcw transceivers
there's none today so if you were to
build one of these you have to either
you have a lot of money and you know
designer for Asic and do a tape out
which is fine if not you need to build
it in the so-called discrete way so you
go and you know buy a discrete waveform
generator a discrete op converter a
discrete you know power amplifier and
connect these either on a PCB or with
you know with transmission lines and you
can build it at least with a few
antennas it's very doable but it becomes
very quickly on manageable if you need
big mimo systems that are pmcw so that's
that's the limitation and that's why
you're not going to go in as much depth
although Again full full everything is
in the slides but I don't want to you
know spend too much time on it on class
so that's high level how ranging works
when there's no Doppler what about when
there's Doppler uh interestingly the
Doppler part of pmcw becomes identical
to fmcw so what you do when it comes to
both you know range and Doppler
estimation you assume that Doppler does
not affect your ranging exactly as we
did for fmcw so basically that phase
term there is a slowly enough that does
not affect the output of your correlator
so you just do your correlation as is
but then you accumulate a bunch of code
words and post correlation you do ffts
on the columns as we did for fmcw and
that fft basically gives you the full
range doppler map or range velocity map
for pmcw
any questions
okay so that basically concludes part
one of uh radar now we're going to start
part two so in part two uh we're gonna
mainly talk about two things uh radar
Target detection and direction of
arrival estimation and direction of
arrival and both of these it they don't
care is it pmcw is it fmcw they operate
on Range velocity Maps which is after
processing range and Doppler whether it
be pmcw or fmcw so that part is does not
matter at all that's why we don't we
don't even make that distinction as as
we talk so uh starting with Target
detection what is Target detection
Target detection is uh if you remember a
few minutes ago when we looked at these
range velocity
Maps uh in there it's kind of like you
can visualize it either as a heat map or
a 3D surface plot targets show as a
strong peaks in there okay and
everything else is noise so the target
detection based basically goes and you
know just just tells you where is where
are the targets and so so you only focus
on those when it comes to direction of
arrival estimation okay so it
distinguishes real targets from noise or
clutter by looking at the range velocity
map so you can kind of think it's going
to be this in the simplest form it's
going to be some thresholding basically
that you do
many different ways of doing it a
simplest one is just you apply a fixed
Global threshold to your range velocity
map and everything that's above a
threshold you declare a Target
everything that's below the threshold
you declare noise or you can do a more
fancy top thresholding a very common one
is called the C4 thresholding or
constant false alarm rate thresholding
and overall goal is to have a high true
positive rate and keep your false
positive as as low as possible so
with the fixed thresholding basically
what you do is that again if I draw a
mini
range doppler map here so the cells
and let's say you have like range on one
axis Doppler on the other axis you can
decide some fixed threshold prefix and
then compare the the magnitude value of
every cell basically the absolute value
of it to that pfix and if that value is
bigger than pfix you you you basically
declare a detection you say Target in
that cell
and if it's below the threshold you say
oh nothing here that's just noise okay
and you do that for the full range
doppler map and that's how you do your
uh basically detections now It's tricky
to decide what a good choice for prefix
should be right because it depends on as
as shubo brought up depends on the SNR
or the noise characteristics which in
many applications are either unknown or
they change over time okay but in the
cases if you have you know a system
where you say you know oh my noise is
some gaussian distributed with a mean
meal and and and variant Sigma then sure
you can choose a prefix that is Mu say
plus three sigma and then that by the
gaussian of Statistics just gives you a
very low false positive rate of 0.13
percent and that's okay but in practice
you know it's not it's not that clean
again either your your noisy statistics
can be complicated it can be on unknown
they're going to change over time with
temperature and things like that or
sometimes there's you know external
interferences that are time varying and
they raise or lower your noise floor so
that's why fixed thresholding is
typically not a good idea except for
very well controlled simple applications
and oftentimes you want to do some
adaptive thresholding such as C4 so very
quickly what we'll look at the math next
time but what C4 calculates is that
again for your range velocity map
what it does that the core idea before
we do any math is that if you have a
Target at some cell these are usually
range velocity amounts as we show in the
previous slides these are pretty spots
like you have a Target and then there's
nothing around it and then there's
another Target you know it's not very a
dense dense map so the idea is that if
if you have a Target in one cell the
cells around it
are mostly noise so if you average the
value of the cells around the Target
that gives you a good idea of the local
noise floor where that Target is so you
can just compare the value of each cell
to the average of the cells around it
and if it's much bigger then you say
that's a Target because around it it's
it's it's it's it's just noise so that's
basically the idea so C4 basically gives
you a per cell instead of one Global
threshold for the entire range doppler
map it calculates a per cell threshold
which is adaptively you know adjusted
and then for each cell if the magnitude
of the range Doppler value is bigger
than the C4 Threshold at that cell so
note that now our threshold is a
function of the cell indices I just
noticed an inconsistency in the in my
notation I think the end should be K
because we used k for
um
after the fft index so sorry about that
I'll correct that but this is Sif of lnk
and uh
so each cell is is compared to a
threshold that is calculated for that
cell if it's larger you declare Target
if not you say that's just noise and
next time we'll look at you know how
actually C4 C4 Works questions
all right let's quit and I'll see you
next time